joining me now to debate this is Dinesh
D'Souza conservative author and
filmmaker and Ethan Berman host of Left
Coast news
all right Dinesh it does seem like every
week
liberals prove a different stereotype
correct I mean we just laid out a few of
them in the angle but we could we do an
entire hour on this on this particular
issue of guns your thoughts well I think
that this vindicates kind of what the
NRA has been warning from the outset at
first for many years I thought that the
NRA was kind of using you may call it
the slippery slope argument which was
essentially that once you start
outlawing one type of weapon you will
then slowly proceed to outlawing the
next type and eventually it becomes a
kind of comprehensive confiscation but I
think what's interesting here is this is
not even a slippery slope it now appears
like there's a whole group of people
that from the outset want a
comprehensive ban and these mass
shootings are making them come out of
the closet you may say rhetorically and
be more and more frank and candid about
what their real agenda is it never was a
kind of targeted or narrowly tailored
law it's ultimately an all-out assault
on the Second Amendment and let's
remember too Lord that the Second
Amendment is no less important than the
First Amendment or the Fourth Amendment
so we should very jealously guard
against these constitutional rights
being being stripped away based upon
some sort of pretext my rights still if
yours if you're going to abuse your
rights the solution is not to take away
my rights all right Ethan I'm gonna get
you in on this because obviously it's a
very hot topic we have these horrific
shootings and people want to end the
shootings of course they do they want to
protect innocent life which is that it
is a incredibly important goal for I
think all Americans on this issue of the
94 ban which in a 94 ban is cited
oftentimes by Democrats but I just laid
out in the angle how the the University
study
that was done to report to the DOJ
couldn't say that it really resulted in
fewer gun deaths yet we have people on
television on MSNBC Joyce Vance said
this watch you know we had a ban on
military assault style weapons in this
country in the 90s and it was successful
and when that band stopped being in
existence because of pressure from the
NRA and other gun supporters that
flooded those weapons back into the
country
well we laid out how only 7% of gun
crimes are committed with guns that are
actually bought from a licensed dealer
so how do you square this Ethan with
this desire for another going back to
the old assault weapons ban well
interestingly enough citing that
University of Pennsylvania study
confirms where beto and Biden are in
saying that we need to have a buyback
program in place because the weapons
were already out there the large
capacity magazines were already out
there banning the sale didn't stop what
was already in circulation furthermore
the great Democrat Ronald Reagan oh
eight Republican Ronald Reagan he said
that look these things we I support this
the the sporting rifles I support home
defense that's what Joe Biden has said
as well
I'm with Ronald Reagan on that one it's
not unfettered and furthermore just ok I
must have missed an Ashton did ronald
reagan push on assault weapons ban
during his eight years - I must have
missed that he and I both worked in
domestic policy at the White House I
don't mean to throw down credentials but
I don't remember that personally but -
maybe you do do you remember that happen
I mean I certainly don't I'd like him to
elaborate a little bit more but I don't
quite know what he's referring to I
don't want that to go we're not
arresting Lee enough beto just tweeted
out the video of Ronald Reagan speaking
and saying those exact words she became
pro-life and on the abortion he changes
them and he supported the he supported
the Brady Bill as well after his
presidency so he clearly supported
regulation of firearms to varying
degrees
Justice Scalia wrote that in section 3
of the Heller vs. DC decision a variety
of regulation
absolutely are supported under our
Second Amendment in our Constitution so
look it is time to end the mass
shootings the key thing that is
consistent here in the United States
that sets us apart from all the other
developed Western nations which have
mental health issues first have violent
video games which have all it is high
rate of fire hundred round per minute up
to semi-automatic right now guns can be
modified but by the way the Reagan's
speech I think I now what you were
talking about he was referring to
machine guns he was not referring and
and bado doesn't know his blank from an
ak-47 they don't said well which is a
fully automatic weapon that is not
allowing enough of Washington DC or any
place in the United States hasn't
they've been bombed this is the thing
that the gun folks gun control folks do
and I like Ethan but you got it you got
talked to here here right Heller
decision did say Justice Scalia did say
doesn't mean that there can be no
regulations on firearms he's and I think
he's right about that he was right about
that in the Heller decision but he
didn't you're making it out like Scalia
said Oh any semi-automatic weapon can be
banned and it remained constitutional
that's not that's not necessarily the
case at all donation that's these are
important details that I think we have
to be very clear on
dinesh I mean number one they're
obviously as with the Second Amendment
there you won there are extreme cases in
which one can regulate the First
Amendment or even the Fourth Amendment
you can't shout fire in a crowded
theater for example but there's a heavy
burden of proof for those who would want
to infringe the constitutional right
number two we have seen even around the
world today cases where the confiscation
and even buyback programs do go Chavez
had a buyback program for guns in
Venezuela the moment that the citizens
were deprived of their guns he unleashed
criminals and so-called colectivos in a
sense state-licensed thugs on the
streets to be able to move into your
apartment take your stuff why because he
had disarmed the citizens and
preparation for that and third we focus
on mass shootings we you know mass
shootings are a little bit of na Milus
whereas there are everyday shootings
occurring in every
major city in this country it's very odd
that those don't lead to demands for gun
control in fact those aren't lead to
demands for anything it seems that only
when there's a mass shooting an
anomalous event there suddenly people go
let's confiscate the guns of everybody
in America because everybody everybody
with an assault rifle poses a threat no
everybody would an assault rifle does
not pose a threat these guys pose a
threat let's identify the threat find
out how we can preempt it and deal with
it in a tailored and narrowly focused
way even do you think the Democrat Party
though has get back getting back to the
angle haven't they they really have
shifted on a whole bunch of issues it
wasn't gonna be healthcare for illegals
now it is would they really weren't for
going in and getting taking guns but now
they pretty much are at least a certain
type of weapons on issue after open
borders well let's not make it a crime
shouldn't be any crime shouldn't have
any you shouldn't you know have bet
really penalties except maybe some civil
deal so they kind of moved on a lot of
these issues they used to wave off these
stereotypes well I think that there is
some truth in what you just said I think
there's a realization that we need to be
stronger on some of these issues the
realization that these people who don't
have proper documentation live amongst
us work amongst us Ronald Reagan again
signed the bill in 1986 that required
emergency rooms to accept them as well I
mean I keep going back to rig and you
guys know so well he signed that
legislation so look the Democrats today
actually have that in common
yeah Ronald Reagan would not recognize
this the current Democrat party he was a
Democrat he wouldn't recognize the party
today
yeah I mean I don't like talking about
people or not with us to sit but I mean
I think he would be shocked to see
what's happened to today's Democrat
Party Thank You panel it's great to see
you tonight